[Musique]
c'est la maison de 16 cola qui ont entre
22 et 61 ans
l'an dernier la majorité d'entre eux
habitaient encore chez leurs parents
ils et elles ont leur propre chambre ils
reçoivent l'assistance continue
nécessaire on les respecte ou tout
toutes les particularités sont respectés
tout ce qu'ils aiment tout ce qui
importe c'est devenu chez eux on
continue d'avoir des défis provoque
toujours continue d'avoir des défis
c'est sûr c'est une population
particulière mais mais les progrès sont
énormes on fait des progrès dans la
communication fallait progrès dans les
interactions entre eux aussi surtout en
fait dans les liens qu'on développe et
donc au début et comique et beaucoup
avec juste les intervenants mais de plus
en plus elles interagissent entre eux
ils font des compliments et famars que
les autres iphone this man show c'est
une maison épuré adaptée aux
particularités des autistes mais c'est
aussi la vision des fondateurs véronique
cloutier et louis morissette qui se sont
laissés guider par le réseau de la santé
bien avant l'inauguration
comment allez-vous aujourd'hui il y à
une éducatrice pour quatre résidents le
programme d'activités vise à les
stimuler et à développer le potentiel de
chacun
[Musique]
un an plus tard ce sont encore les mêmes
résidant pour la plupart le je voudrais
que après six mois
l'intégration s'est quand même fait mais
on les connaissait pas par coeur puis
même après 1,1 en eux qu'ils nous
surprennent encore l'équipe a vraiment
tout fait pour
que ces résidents le sadap soit compris
parce qu'il y en a plein qui sont non
verbale si jamais il ya des crises ou
des désorganisations sait quoi faire
maintenant de partout au québec cathy
taille on reçoit des messages de parents
le modèle est encore à l'essai et quatre
études universitaires vont permettre de
l'évaluer le centre de santé et de
services sociaux de la montérégie ouest
qui finance les services offerts à la
maison véro et louis et qui gère aussi
les demandes d'hébergement y voient la
possibilité de faire mieux en regroupant
les clientèles qui se ressemblent je
pense que pourquoi on commence de plus
en plus avoir des profils de solution
résidentielle personnalisés c'est
justement parce que on s'adapte plus aux
besoins de l'usager dans les dernières
années que peut-être avant l'été est
plus dans une institutionnalisation
alors les autres gros bras droit qui
collait sa veuve est très très très bien
répondre aussi aux besoins plus
sensorielle comme la magie qui apportent
parfois les zoos thérapie aucun
participant ainsi qu'il fait semblant
d'être heureux c'est naturel c'est des
réactions spontanées des vrais réactions
ci sont pas capables face en blanc puis
quand ils veulent pas ils disent c'est
super correct parce que pour certains
travaillent sauce il de dire non
dès l'automne on souhaite ouvrir
certaines activités deux jours à des
adultes autistes du secteur
ici anne louise despatie radio-canada à
varennes
[Musique]